[Musique]
on a aujourd'hui une surenchère de
normes parce que à la fois il y a
beaucoup de projets de loi il y a des
exigences de sécurité des exigences en
matière environnementale et aujourd'hui
les élus dans le on va dire le top 3 de
leurs difficultés de leur récrimination
arrivent ce sujet des nombres beaucoup
trop compliqué beaucoup de choses
strictes et surtout extrêmement coûteuse
qu'elles ont fait perdre aux élus le
pouvoir d'agir et le pouvoir de gère
c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel en responsabilité tout à
l'heure vous avez vu que les chiffres de
la Commission nationale d'évaluation des
normes du Sénat pour une fois du
ministère concordé
surco léonorme dans l'année 2021 c'est 2
milliards et demi à un moment où
l'argent public rare il faut se poser
des questions ce qu'on fait ce matin
c'est une démarche qui ressemble au
Sénat on part du terrain et on fait du
pragmatique on part du terrain puisqu'il
y a eu ces échanges avec la Direction
générale des collectivités locales avec
les communes et on fait du pragmatique
donc on n'invente pas une nouvelle
structure on dit il y a un conseil
national d'évaluation des normes il
existe il fait du bon boulot on va plus
s'appuyer là dessus
il pointe pas à responsable il dit on a
plein de sources nouvelles de normes il
y a évidemment le gouvernement mais il y
a législateur parfois il peut y avoir
des fédérations professionnelles qui est
dit des règles on va faire en sorte que
chacun
s'autodiscipline et on va se fixer un
objectif pragmatique pour que ça
fonctionne puisque au travers de la
signature de la charte on va venir
vérifier la tenue de ces engagements
[Musique]